and I did something to him that my
brothers did to me that used to drive me
crazy they used to put Tabasco sauce on
my fingertips when I was sleeping
well because the first thing you do when
you wake up in the morning is what rub
my eyes and just hope that you're not
gonna screw with me on a daily basis
you go pink
anybody who's there
who's there yeah that's not fun I put
the basketball sauce on his fingertips
and I just wait
I wait five in the morning I get up I
sit in the living room and I hear him go
to the bathroom just you know got up to
go to the bathroom and it's pretty just
normal
box he walks into the living room
[Applause]
[Music]
as I'm walking out of the bathroom
there's a feeling that I've definitely
never felt before
[Music]
hey
I was concerned my junk is on fire
and I don't know why
and I don't like that I said hey he goes
what does it mean
what
if your penis is on fire
[Applause]
and for those of you who don't know the
answer to that question actually a lot
of things if it hurts go talk to your
doctor it's very important and you
should seek medical attention right away
it could mean a lot of things so you're
like what like what like what
is that why you could
you do I'm alive will they take a needle
you stick it in the base of your penis
what a penis shot I don't want one of
those
penis shot also just sounds like a
nutshell like it just sounds like
somebody getting kicked in the nuts or
hitting the nuts it sounds like
something kids in middle school penis
shot gank what is there any other option
I go well yeah I said with it you could
have like a bacterial infection oh okay
what is that what does that mean how do
they fix that I go well they take a
needle
all right
let's put the needle they stick it in
the basement oh another Peter shot
oh I don't wanna is there any option
besides penis shot hear me out if I ever
find myself in a scenario where the only
option is a penis shot
you better have me knocked out because I
am not going out without a fight well is
there any option besides paint a shot I
I
don't I go on this and one the Third
that's so rare like
it never happens he's like what is it
I'm like it just doesn't happen he goes
what is it is it a Peter shot I go no he
was telling me what it is
like okay I go it's possible but it
never happens but it's possible
did somebody snuck into your room and
put Tabasco sauce on your fingertips
when you're sleeping
Tabasco sauce on the fingertips
definitely not something I'll ever
forget but something I may use in the
future like usual please hit the
Subscribe button make sure you throw a
like on there and throw a comment down
there thank you guys for tuning in once
again and we shall see you on the next
one